thank you
hey guys now some of you who's been
following me for a while you know that
I'm very direct but whatever I say to
you it comes from the right place from a
good place with a lot of love
and there's one big thing that's been on
my mind a lot lately these last few
months
when I look at what guys are doing
even guys that I know personally and
this one thing gives you a bad name and
it influences all your relationships you
can be a good guy look presentable
kind positive have good manners be well
dressed and always be there when someone
needs you but if you do this one thing
it can destroy all the other things in
an instant
in most cases
guys don't even know they don't see how
this influences the way that other
people see them you might just brush it
off and think oh well it's fine I
understand
meantime they just don't want to say
anything because they don't want to
create a scene the way they look at you
as a person changes totally and this one
thing is so important because
it influences your name and at the end
of the day your name is all you really
have
Shannon Alder said carve your name on
Hearts not tombstones a legacy is edged
into the minds of others and the stories
they share about you so what is this one
thing that can give you a bad name
not being a man of your word
there are many men today who do not keep
their promises even when it comes to
things like I'll bring it to you on
Monday or I will help you with that next
week or I'll visit you on Saturday or
I'll call you tomorrow but then they do
not keep their word so they break trust
and Trust as one of the rarest things
that you can find in this world words
carry white so think before you say
anything to anyone your yes should
always be yes and you're no no
Jesus said in Matthew 5 37 let what you
say be simply yes or no anything more
than this comes from evil
if you don't keep your word it is
disgusting think about it whenever
someone promises you something and they
don't keep their word how do you feel
you don't feel great right so why do you
do it to other people whenever somebody
promises me something and if they don't
keep their promise I don't mention it
I just ignore it but I never look at
that person the same again
because I won't trust them
the same way I used to
I forgive them because we have to
forgive people right because we all have
sinful fleshly Natures there's nobody
that's perfect in this world but
forgiveness and trust those are two
different things
so think about the man the type of man
you are right now and the type of man
you want to be
and start working towards that real men
are men who keep their promises who keep
their word so be a man of your word and
always remember life is short so don't
waste yours cheers guys